-How are you? Welcome back
-I'm great.
-Well, thanks for having
me back.
-I want to get right into it
You were an actual
communications director
at a White House.
-Not a celebrated one at that.
-No.
Well, we didn't realize
at the time how important
it was to have
communications directed.
-Yeah.
-But you worked in the
Bush White House,
and now you are seeing
this White House,
which is not --
I would say communications
is not its strength.
To be fair,
they have very few strengths
But what do you feel
at a time like this,
when messaging is so important
How do you perceive
what's happening right now
-So, this is one of those things
that I wish we were wrong about,
people who are critical
and who see the flaws.
This is one of those ones wher
when Donald Trump says,
"Oh, a miracle is going to tak
corona away,"
that's like the one-in-a-million
things where I'm like,
"Ooh, I wish he were right."
-But the prob-- And, look,
here's the other thing.
I mean, we have
a global pandemic,
and he's "liar, liar,
pants on fire" president
who saw this coming.
I mean, this was where it wa
always going to land.
-Right.
-We were always going to nee
him to have more credibility
on the world stage,
to level with us,
and to be more competent
than he is
when our health and our family's
health was on the line.
And, sadly, it took somethin
like this, I think,
to even shake the confidence o
some members of his base.
A virus doesn't have
a political affiliation.
-I guess time will tell
if it actually
is shaking the confidence
of his base,
because it is interesting.
Certainly, in the early stages
we are seeing
very smart people,
very talented people
who are trying to deal
with this crisis who are,
as we pointed out, also trying
to do this sort of
triangulation of also figuring
out how not to offend him.
Are you surprised
when you see --
-Oh, the "dear leader" stuff
-Yeah.
When you see brilliant doctors
who are making
the choice to say like,
"And, also,
let me just say you are
doing a really good job, too."
-Yeah, look, I don't know wher
that chip comes from.
I mean, I think it's part of
the reward structure.
And he's very, you know,
off with your head,
anyone that doesn't tell him
he's brilliant.
But, I mean, you cover the sam
stories I do every day.
The things people say to him
especially when the
public safety is on the line
are really, really troubling
-You obviously went throug
some crises
in your time as
a communications director.
Each is different.
How did you deal with
the ones that you faced
in your time in The White House?
-We were ready for the bird flu.
That was the pandemic
that we were prepared for.
And people like to joke that
Bush wasn't steeped in history
but he read every -- He wa
reading books about the plague
We were all given sort of
take-home reading
about how things spread.
We were drilling
on Saturdays and Sundays,
red teams and blue teams,
for how something would,
you know, go from city to city
And you look at the way this
White House communicates,
it's all about goosing
the stock market.
I mean, no one even seems
to have in mind --
I don't -- You know,
if you've got kids in school
and you go to work,
you rely on sort of
the infrastructure and the
trustworthy flow of informatio
to make decisions about how to
keep your family safe.
And that's where I think
if this goes on, no one is -
Again, the coronavirus is no
Donald Trump's fault,
but everything he's done i
exaggerating about the statu
of tests and lying about
its severity
and saying it will just
go away, that's all on him
-Well, we talked
about this, as well,
the idea that it's not
his fault -- right? --
that it started,
but if it had
started under Obama,
Donald Trump would be
the guy on "Fox & Friends"
saying it was his fault.
-He was.
-It was Obama's fault.
-During Ebola,
he was on Twitter every day,
saying, you know, "Keep them all
out, lock the borders."
I mean, during Ebola, he did
more fearmongering than anyone
-I feel like somebody
should go to him and say,
"Hey, you don't have to do thi
because you're Donald Trump,
And there's not another one like
you out there right now."
-I feel like someone
should go and say,
"Look, we've had
to take down the comms.
The Wi-Fi is out
And you're going to have three
weeks to golf, no Twitter.
And his approval rating
would go up.
-Yeah.
-We'd be safer.
-But he couldn't stay off --
His approval rating would go up.
The doctors could function
without, as you said,
the, you know, intermittent,
"Dear Leader, you're so good
at science" baloney.
And we would have
a direct line of communication
from real experts.